driving past the Russian embassy in Kiev
is a reminder of the perilous state of
Russian Ukrainian relations the walls
and windows built to sustain blasts it
looks a bit like Fort Knox and next to
it just in case Russian diplomats should
ever forget the names of the 24
Ukrainian sailors held in a Moscow jail
ever since Russia opened fire on their
ships in November last year on Sunday
night flush with victory Ukraine's new
president-elect said that the sailors
release was his first priority [ __ ] 188
I met the mothers of our sailors I will
do all I can to return them I cannot
promise that to you but I will do
everything so that our guys returned
home Petro poroshenko tried to portray
Vladimir's Olinsky as a soft touch to
Vladimir Putin would trample all over
but mr. szalinski is as much an unknown
quantity to Moscow as he is to
Ukrainians
we went to speak to Victor medvedchuk a
Ukrainian citizen but close friend of
Vladimir Putin who is godfather to his
daughter called the grey Cardinal in
Kiev at medvedchuk has long acted as an
intermediary between Moscow and Kiev
plain America if we are talking about
the 22 imprisoned sailors and to SBU
agents he should negotiate with Russia
follows the pernicious path of
poroshenko pressured the international
community and demanded strengthening of
sanctions and other measures against
Russia sup Adam what nisonger is he at
any price Patrol what conversations have
you had with Vladimir Putin about mr.
szalinski has he asked you about him
this woman was bulldozed overnight at
you know
yamo nobody will talk to you later Jesus
never know saying I told him only what
is public knowledge because I don't know
more anymore than what I see in the
media what he said publicly one of mr.
solinsky's greatest challenges will be
the ongoing war against Russian backed
separatists in the east which has
already claimed some 13,000 lives
the Kremlin today said it was too early
for President Putin to send his
congratulations that judgments should be
based on deeds but Moscow is watching
with interest people in Ukraine I
believe clearly show the they want to
have changes they want to see changes
political changes changes in approaches
towards Russia from Ukraine so in case
mr. Zaleski will be able to interpret
these elections and the outcome of this
election in that manner I believe he
will be able to draw the right
conclusions a complicated mandate for a
comedian turned commander-in-chief Diana
Magnay Sky News give